Not so easy to sort out who's the good ones and who's the bad water.
Sort of like where you were talking about this.
People that have this simplistic idea that all you have to do is get Donald
Trump high on DMT and he's going to see the light.
That's not necessarily the case.
Not necessarily the case.
I think it would be wasted on him.
I think we would have to do at least an indwelling catheter may be two or three
hours of continuous DMP fusion that,
sorry,
sorry.
Wrong,
wrong term.
Intravenous,
but it's very,
very Freudian.
You decided to go through his Dick,
right?
That is hilarious.
Not,
not that we'll,
we'll go through the vape.
I don't know man.
I think it might have nailed it the first time.
That might be the way to get it.
Maybe the way to get it to them is perfect.
Russian robot fucked off.
Locks him up and right when he gets inside of her.
There you go.
She gets them in full guard.
Locks them in place and a catheter like delivery.
Yeah.
Maybe they can program it like,
like Dmt,
like little nanobots that go right through the penis hole right into the system.
They just run out of her right in there and he's ball.
He just takes off.
But again,
there has to be something there.
How many animators that have an effect,
please?
So many anime thing.
I know there's somebody out there that wants to do it
the way to do it.
Just some perfect,
super hot.
10 Russian hooker looking chick.
No offense to Russian hookers,
right?
Or Donald Trump.